NARRATOR 1: At first, this photo
doesn't look that significant.
It's just a guy taking a
break during some hike.
But if you were to zoom
out, you'd see this.
That guy is chilling here,
on Mount Everest, the tallest
and most dangerous
mountain on earth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The photographer alongside
him was this guy.
DAVID RUIZ: Hi, my
name is David Ruiz.
I'm from Barcelona, Spain.
NARRATOR 1: David
and the other hikers
in his group stopped
at the Black Rock
to acclimate to
the thinning air.
From here, they begin the
hardest part of their climb
up Island Peak, 6200
meters in the sky.
NARRATOR 1: Hundreds of extreme
adventurers and climbers
come from all over the world
to summit Everest each year,
but they can't do it alone
if they want to survive.
They require expert
guides to lead the way.
NARRATOR 1: Sherpas, meaning
Eastern People in Tibetan,
are highly skilled mountaineers
raised in the heart of Nepal's
Himalayas.
They've been guiding explorers
in the region for decades.
Trekking Mount Everest
is their day job.
That's why this guy
looks so at ease.
He was just catching a
break between summits
and had seen this before,
but, to David, this
was an amazing moment.
NARRATOR 1: This
[INAUDIBLE] aims
to share captivating photos
and the stories behind them.
If you like this video,
be sure to check out this
on Eagle Hunters in Mongolia.
NARRATOR 2: The eagles
are used to hunt primarily
foxes, wolves, marmots,
which the hunters obviously
use for food in
the harsh winters,
and they also use the fur
from animals for clothing.
NARRATOR: And, as always,
thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]